well season two of the Trump presidency
is getting off to a pretty fast start
Donald Trump and a lot of his staffers
have now been caught in a just massive
I mean gargantuan monstrous lie
yesterday and it relates to that
resignation of the White House staff
secretary Rob Porter that we've been
talking about we now know that Rob
Porter was accused of beating not one
but two ex-wives and he's no longer
working for the Trump administration but
still as far as we know dating Donald
Trump's communications director hope
Hicks although that will probably be a
story for a different day
I predict although today I don't have
news about that for you and the
questions about Rob Porter have been
when did the White House know that a
security clearance was going to be a
problem for Porter because of the
allegations that were out there against
him and the Trump White House and Trump
and people around Trump they've all been
insisting multiple times that they just
didn't know right that we just had no
idea we found out very recently for the
first time and nobody knew anything
nobody was cover anything up nobody was
allowing Porter to be here despite
knowing that he had serial wife-beating
allegations out there against him
however we now heard from FBI director
Christopher Ray who testified yesterday
and in no uncertain certain terms
whatsoever said listen we started
communicating with the Trump White House
about Rob Porter's issues in March of
2017 nearly a year ago here is
Christopher Rea the FBI director who of
course is only there because of the
chain of events started by Donald
Trump's firing of James Comey completely
contradicting what the White House has
told us about what they knew and went
about Rob Porter vice chairman Warner
highlighted in his opening statement the
importance of an effective security
clearance process right so I've got a
question for you director Ray was the
FBI aware of allegations related to Rob
Porter and domestic abuse and if so was
the White House
formed this could affect his security
clearance when were they informed right
and who at the White House was informed
well senator there's a limit to what I
can say about the content of any
particular background investigation for
a variety of reasons that I'm sure you
can appreciate I would say that the
background investigation process
involves a fairly elaborate set of
standards guidelines protocols
agreements etc that have been in place
for 20-plus years and I'm quite
confident that in this particular
instance the FBI followed established
protocols so was the White House
informed that this could affect his
security clearance that's a yes or no
right I can't get into the content of
what was briefed what what what I can
tell you is that the FBI submitted a
partial report on the investigation in
question in March and then a completed
background investigation in late July
huh that is soon thereafter we received
requests for follow-up inquiry and we
did the follow-up and provided that
information in November and that we
administrative leak losed the file in
January and then earlier this month we
received some additional information and
we pass that on as well that's right
the FBI's have been at a partial report
almost a year ago in March of 2017
they finished the background in July of
2017 and then they had further follow-up
later on in 2017 but the resignation
didn't happen until February of 2018 and
they're all complicit in the lies deputy
press secretary Raj Shah said last
Thursday that the background
investigation was ongoing well they had
an initial completion of that background
investigation in July of 2017 press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders and
all-around horrible person said
something very similar when asked really
specifically whether last Tuesday was
the first
time that any of this was known and
here's how Sarah Huckabee Sanders
responded to the question specifically
though had he learned at any time before
last Tuesday when this story was broken
by the Daily Mail that there was any
allegation of any sort leveled by any
person against Rockport again I can't
get into the specifics I can tell you
that we were the process for the
background was ongoing and the White
House had not received any specific
papers regarding the completion of that
background check so I can't go any
further than what we've already said on
that the White House had received no
specific papers except that they had
according to FBI director frist at
Christopher ray they had received all
the papers because the investigation had
been closed and it gets even worse
because it is now being reported that
Porter almost became deputy chief of
staff had this not been broken by media
outlets we might have had Rob Porter
deputy chief of staff there's a tweet
from CNN's Brooke Baldwin saying that
Caitlin Collins is reporting that just
before Rob Porter resigned amid the
allegations of spouse abuse the White
House was considering promoting him to
deputy chief of staff while they dodged
that bullet I guess we could say and
then the most recent wrinkle is that
Sarah Huckabee Sanders says that even
though it appears as though the White
House is saying one thing and the FBI is
saying something different that they're
both somehow telling the truth the White
House is telling the truth and
Christopher Rea is telling the truth
which seems hard to believe because
they're saying very very different
things but here is once again Sarah
Huckabee Sanders
the investigation was ongoing mr. Perret
said it was close I was telling the
truth both as I said the FBI portion was
closed the White House personnel
security office yeah who is the one that
makes a recommendation for adjudication
had not finished their process and
therefore not made a recommendation to
the White House just clarify one more
point you said yesterday you didn't get
any paperwork from the FBI Chris Ray
said that again that would come through
the White House personnel Security
office not completed their investigation
and not pass that information to the
White House that you did receive people
again the White House I think you need
to be very clear about there's multiple
groups here listen you need to
understand that the internal mail system
of the White House sometimes things
aren't properly postage so just because
you send papers doesn't mean that the
papers are received
it's an unintelligible explanation and I
don't plan on spending too much more
time on the Rob Porter thing
specifically although its repercussions
I'm glad to continue talking about
because as vile as it is it just
confirms what we already knew about the
White House Pat which is that there's
some undeniable realities here when it
comes to sexual abuse right and lying
number one this confirms Trump lies and
people around him lie we knew that
already
number two it confirms that Trump and
people around him don't really care
about sexual assault right exhibit a
being Trump is president and has more
than a dozen sexual assault allegations
against him and that's why they covered
for Porter so long it just wasn't a big
deal to them that he was accused of
beating multiple ex-wives well it is
pretty odd to me why the White House
would face all his political retribution
for the sake of Rob Porter yeah
especially cuz it's not as if Trump is
opposed to firing people he was doing it
once a week but I think he just doesn't
take sexual abuse very seriously he
always angry and he never believes the
women it just doesn't really matter
right that's the point it wasn't some
concerted effort to cover up reporter
they just don't care about domestic
abuse and sexual assault and if it
doesn't it's not even clear his voters
care about it because they voted for
Trump despite those dozen allegations if
they cared about this Trump wouldn't be
president in the first place
so the way that this has
been carried out is really no surprise
whatsoever the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership